[MUSIC PLAYING]
This is the skull of a pachycephalosaur,
a 16 foot long plant eater.
Despite years of research, we're still
trying to understand why it had this bizarre shaped head.
[GROWLING]
The most distinctive feature about the pachycephalosaurs,
of course, is this really weird dome
that they have on their head.
All around it is a series of very old tubercles and nobles
and bobbles.
They look quite dragon-like.
When they first saw these very thick domed skulls--
and these domes could be up to 30 centimeters in thickness--
they were thought to be very strong.
It was thought that maybe they were using them
for headbutting each other in contests over social hierarchy.
Today, animals like bighorn sheep butt heads in this way.
A thickened skull helps protect their brain from impact.
But does this fully explain pachycephalosaur's domed head?
A number of paleontologists thought
they should look inside the skulls.
They sliced up a number of pachycephalosaur domes.
And when they did that, they found out
that maybe it wasn't strong enough
to withstand these direct head on impacts.
However, they did discover something else,
suggesting the dome had a different use.
The surface was marked with a mesh of tiny fibers.
Perhaps they supported brightly colored skin
used to attract a mate.
This new theory seemed to be accepted until 2013,
when a new discovery was made.
A pachycephalosaur was found with marks
showing it had survived multiple injuries
to the top of its head.
And it wasn't a one-off.
They went back and looked through historic museum
collections and discovered that actually there
was quite a lot of evidence for these lesions
in a similar place across a whole bunch
of different pachycephalosaurs.
This is good evidence that they probably were head butting.
So were the skulls strong enough to protect pachycephalosaur's
brain after all?
To find out, scientists turned to the latest
scanning technology.
We can use CT scans to build virtual models of the bones.
And then we can subject those to various engineering tests
in the same way that we do with an airplane
part or an artificial hip.
This provided the final piece of evidence.
What they've shown is that pachycephalosaur domes
could actually have withstood an enormous amount of force.
It's a sort of force that goes through American footballers
when they hit each other.
We now believe pachycephalosaurs used their head
both as a formidable weapon, and as a colorful display--
two ways to demonstrate who was boss
in their prehistoric world.